hey guys first of all thank you for
clicking you're about to watch a new
video or another video on YouTube and
before we do - one two nine three one
two five seven three one what I'm doing
in my text community is bonkers it's
instant it's access it's exclusive and
now enjoy this YouTube video I actually
don't give a [ __ ] about this okay like
like if you're really really like really
I wish if you were here no success like
financially but happy is [ __ ] I'd be
super I would [ __ ] hug you and be
like bro you [ __ ] one life you've got
your perspective again my face kind of
like perfect maybe a professor have
whatever you want to do like this is the
place and the category of content that
most people get caught they become super
mundane and putting out the same kinds
of pictures because they're feeding the
algorithm and putting out photos that
they know will work thus eventually
making all their photos look the same I
would rather have underperforming photos
and mix it up because it gives me the
potential to actually find the next
pillar of pictures that expand my
audience stop fearing the algorithm
Dustin got that whole thing I think you
should cut it I want it for bait him I'm
I'm gonna make it I'm actually a little
bit tricky I got my little like pseudo
like um like a large Simpson like kind
of like well nah I mean this was the
this was the cartooning that I
consistently drew like this is basically
what I did in school from 7th to 11th
grade I drew this guy in every like
literally in every class like in every
class this dude
it's pretty good thanks bro thanks bro
post it but by the way this is very meta
right like like the fact that like right
now like literally we're in this meeting
trying to teach people like that they're
overthinking you know content and like
I've got a Tweetup already gonna reply
to that tweet I'm going into my
Instagram story boom
now the kindnesses King boom done I'm
gonna snap boom now I'm doing this you
know what's good if you're confused
kindnesses King now I have a snap boom
boom boom boom boom good now I'm going
on Instagram live I mean this is like
I'm alive
yo Instagram I just drew this
it's my guide from 7th to 11th grade
that I used to draw all the time
kindness is king I'm going live I'm
working on a deck for you guys right now
it's super meta Dustin's making a vlog
it's like this is how it's done [ __ ]
make stop thinking start making do you
put a calm after I mean I know I'm the
worst of grammar if you're good kamma
people because I was like if you're good
people can we this needs to go on social
this is I mean I'm more likely I am more
likely to find a $400,000 rare jewel at
a trash talk episode than what just
happened here with a proper
understanding of grammar oh my god mrs.
Horvath we did it
[Music]
my why I'm here is I don't know how to
monetize what I'm doing I've had a lot
of bumps in the road where I don't know
how do where to go from here some on
eBay what would you like to happen make
more be more successful in theory yeah
and then what about happiness where you
on the to me it's it's really when I
hear that questions here's all I think
about right hey guys sorry to interrupt
your video I'm just giving you this call
for my number to let you know that you
have to join my text community to one
two nine three one five seven three one
hit me up with a text happiness right
and and like financial success right
right and like and as you know I don't
think people are talking about that
enough right right so like I want you
here and I think people are focused too
much here which makes them unhappy and
that's why they burn out so for me when
you ask that question I'm trying to
figure this out do you get the vibe on
here I go no okay no but but anybody who
sells something is actually in a real
business right so at least you have the
chance plus your [ __ ] basement look
good so I you know no I don't get the
vibe you're here you may or may not be
here's actually that was a really
interesting insight by you
I actually don't give a [ __ ] about this
okay like like if you're really really
like really I wish if you were here no
success like financially but happiest
[ __ ] right I'd be super I would [ __ ]
hug you and be like bro you [ __ ] one
life right this is obviously what like a
lot of people are trying to figure out
listen I'm here you know you a quick
thing on this yes okay because the one
place I'm most scared of is here okay a
lot of people get here and lose this is
the people I'm going after and an
obviously just and obviously this scares
the super [ __ ] out of me that fumbles
well this is the worst spot right you
know right beta media is not your
typical agency we are fueled by an
Oriol spirit and grounded in three g's
of generosity grind and gratitude next
so I always get out of things that are
booked for four d-roc were you with me
when we had that for our booking for
something and we're done like 20 minutes
hey what's happening I'm a little bit
confused are we doing admin so am i
calling this kids we can we just not
three hour meeting I want you to fill me
you can ask our would but I think it's
good for the archives I also doing a
time lapse I'm just showing for the vlog
I mean otherwise what's the vlog today
where I get it but like but I think
adding this up doing like one and a half
minutes of a three hour time lapse
showing that I have three four hour
meetings with gallery media group 1:37
p.m. pure I was a good look for them
good look for all of us
[Music]
hello hello hello how are you come on
nice - pleasure how are you so what's up
good to see you guys
[Music]